[Music]
so basically there are a woven material
with adhesive and polymer and when you
wet it it attaches to the skin and you
leave it on for five to ten minutes
usually and when you pull it off you'll
see sort of these like stalagmite
stalactite type things on me strip and
that's actually oil from your skin that
gets oxidized and turns black in color
as well as bacteria dead skin hair dirt
basically anything that's on the surface
just gets pulled off a deep cleansing
doesn't happen with these strips
although your skin may feel cleaner
smoother they really don't do anything
prevent you from developing blackheads
I totally get that they're satisfying
but I don't think over long periods of
time they do much for you other things
should be used
retinoids and retinols and chemical
peels can all be used in conjunction
with poor strips some people are worried
that they can break capillaries very
rarely can it cause significant damage
although I do see patients all the time
with lots of irritation particularly if
they're using it frequently using four
strips responsibly is really important
you don't want to use them more than
once a week you want to make sure your
skin is clean before you use them you
want to follow the directions don't
leave them on for longer than they say
always remove the adhesive to prevent
irritation and cleanse your face after
people who have allergies to different
cosmetic products should just be a
little bit careful sometimes I'll tell
people to put them on their arms first
just to make sure that they aren't
sensitive and then put them on the face
although I really don't tell patients to
use them necessarily if people like them
I am NOT telling people not to use them
I mean I totally get it
they're fun I use them too sometimes
[Music]